[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est il possible de reproduire toutes les
facultés cognitives humaine ou même
juste reproduire des émotions humaines
de façon complètement artificielle ce
serait assez fou c'est possible non pour
ma part je suis ingénieur dans
l'intelligence artificielle et je n'ai
encore jamais fait ça et même pour être
honnête je ne verrai même pas par où
commencer
après vous me direz ok j'ai peut-être
raté un truc noël autour de la table ma
grand mère me demande d'y donc mon
garçon je travaille dans quoi toi bats
mamie tu sais bien je suis ingénieur
dans l'intelligence artificielle ah oui
ces robots dotés de facultés inouïe bon
sur le coup ça ne m'a pas fait plaisir
mais j'ai choisi de ne rien dire de tout
simplement changer de sujet aujourd'hui
avec vous je me dis qu'il faudrait quand
même arrivé à démêler le vrai du faux
pour beaucoup
mon métier est assez floue voire
menaçants je me suis même aperçu pour
penser que je crée des armées de robots
avec des facultés exceptionnelles
et vous quelle est votre vision
quels mots vous vient à l'esprit lorsque
vous entendez le mot intelligence
artificielle conscience robot humanoïde
peut-être si vous êtes dans ce registre
là je vous le dis carrément il ya mes
compréhension de ce qu'est vraiment
l'intelligence artificielle de ses
potentialités actuelles et futures
aussi je vous propose de voir avec moi
l'envers du décor parce que oui dans la
réalité je suis un mathématicien et
informaticien qui développe des
algorithmes d'apprentissage et vous
allez me demander mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça ce sont des formules
mathématiques et oui les maths viau
collège lycée n'était pas là juste comme
ça ça peut vraiment être applicable on
dit intelligence artificielle mais c'est
un terme un peu brute qui a paru dans
les années 50
c'est lors d'une conférence que des
chercheurs ont présenté une innovation
qui permettait de reproduire les
capacités de raisonnement d'un problème
d'un être humain à partir de ce moment
il a été approuvé que le terme
intelligence artificielle pouvait être
adopté pourquoi ça comment expliquer que
des chercheurs ont réussi à créer des
intelligences artificielles sans avoir
une puissance de calcul digne de ce nom
tout simplement parce que derrière une
intelligence artificielle
il y a des maths et seulement des maths
autant de connaissances que nous
comprenons et surtout que nous
maîtrisons comme on a tous vu l école de
l'algèbre linéaire des statistiques
des probabilités d'ailleurs vous vous
souvenez de cette fameuse formule y égal
à x + b qui en a sûrement traumatisé
plus d'un cette formule fait partie de
ce que l'on appelle intelligence
artificielle
aujourd'hui dans la majorité des cas
l'intelligence artificielle est un
système d'apprentissage
mon job c'est de créer et concevoir des
programmes d'apprentissage
le programme a une tâche bien spécifique
à effectuer et pour y arriver il va
apprendre c'est à dire qu'il va faire
des répétitions à travers lesquels il va
s'améliorer ici c'est un peu comme
l'humain pour s'améliorer
on va vous donner des règles à appliquer
et pour être sûr qu'on applique bien ces
règles on va avoir un indicateur qui
nous dit là c'est faux il faut faire
autrement
et au fil des essais des répétitions
vous allez faire passer ce faux en vrai
de plus en plus fréquemment et vous vous
en doutez l'intelligence artificielle
dans ce sens là est déjà présente
tout autour de nous elle est déjà
inscrite dans notre quotidien sans que
l'on s'en rende forcément content
prenons une matinée un petit pique je me
lève je prends ma douche
personnellement j'adore chanter sous la
douche
donc je crie à mon assistant personnel
alexa mais moi mais disney préférés sur
spotify ici deux intelligences
artificielles reconnaissance vocale et
recommandations de musique j'ai fini que
je m'habille puis je développe mon
téléphone avec mon visage intelligence
artificielle
je regarde mes mails et derrière il y a
une intelligence artificielle
qui me permet de ne pas recevoir trop de
spam je pars prendre mon p'tit déj
en même temps je regarde une série
netflix génial ils vont à recommander
une adaptée à mon profil intelligence
artificielle
j'ai fini je pars à mon travail en
voiture je mets wise
celui ci me calcule le chemin optimal
pour me rendre intelligence artificielle
bon vous l'aurez compris l'intelligence
artificielle est déjà tout autour de
nous et croyez moi j'ai pris les cas les
plus flagrants
les plus parlants mais il y en a encore
bien plus et même pour être honnête les
entreprises veulent encore monter en
puissance dessus on parle toujours pas
des robots ici tout ce que j'ai évoqué
ce sont des outils dans notre quotidien
ils sont utiles ou pas ça ça dépend de
chacun mais ça restait des outils
l'intelligence artificielle est un outil
ça peut être très pratique dans mon
quotidien comme le compliqué ici c'est
vraiment à nous de décider ce que nous
voulons en faire on peut voir
l'intelligence artificielle comme un
couteau dans mon quotidien ça peut être
très très pratique pour couper ma viande
mes légumes
par contre entre de mauvaises mains
là c'est plus la même l'intelligence
artificielle peut faire peur certains
peuvent penser qu'elle peut gouverner le
monde qu'elle va tous nous détruire quel
va être incontrôlables c'est un sujet
qui peut être anxiogène qui pour
certains fait gamberger
mais pas rêver et avec de telles idées
des problématiques éthiques se posent
actuellement sur l'intelligence
artificiel alors qu'en fait même les
plus grands courts ou de l'intelligence
artificielle disent qu'on a des
décennies de pouvoir créer quelque chose
qui se rapprocherait de toute la
complexité de l'intelligence humaine et
même dans le futur
il ya encore de gros débats entre les
chercheurs sur la tournure que ça
prendra d'ailleurs si vous avez un chat
ou un chien chez vous celui ci est bien
plus intelligent qu'une quelconque
intelligence artificielle
bon ok on est d'accord ils peuvent avoir
des comportements irrationnels encore la
dernière fois mon chat couru à travers
les pièces pour se prendre la porte
malgré tout il a des émotions
il sait interagir gaieté et du kiss et
chatons rêver toutes ses capacités qui
fonde votre chat un chat l'humain
aujourd'hui ne sait pas le reproduire de
façon artificielle de ce fait à mon sens
les problématiques éthiques de
l'intelligence artificielle en mode un
peu
terminator ne sont pas pertinentes
elles peuvent même masquer les vraies
problématiques de l'intelligence
artificielle
on l'a dit l'intelligence artificielle
est un système d'apprentissage mais pour
apprendre il faut apprendre à partir de
quelque chose non ce fameux programme
d'apprentissage il apprend à partir de
quoi c'est en se posant ces questions
que l'on commence à toucher du doigt à
mon sens aux réelles problématiques de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
oui
elle apprend à partir des données en
général mais aussi à partir de nos
données tout le sujet sensible et là ce
sont nos informations très précieuses
tout l'enjeu est là qu est ce que vous
êtes prêts à livrer de vos données de
vous pour que cet apprentissage soit
pertinent par rapport à votre profil à
vous est ce que aujourd'hui j'ai
vraiment le contrôle sur tout ça et je
dirais même est ce que aujourd'hui je
suis en mesure de vivre sans
intelligence artificielle
c'est à ces questions que je vous invite
à réfléchir intelligemment bien sûr et
ma grand mère dans tout ça mamie
j'espère que tu as compris toi qui est
connecté toi qui sauf s'il te plaît fais
attention à tes données
merci à tous